196 états et l'union européenne seront
représentés à la coop 26 à glasgow ainsi
que des ong des villes des entreprises
leur objectif commun au moins de façade
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique les conclusions du giec le
groupe de 234 scientifique de 66 pays a
prédit des événements apocalyptiques
si les pays ne s'accordaient pas sûr
d'eloise intransigeante pour baisser les
émissions de co2 d'ici quelques années
la hausse du niveau des mers des
phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes une
chute dramatique de la biodiversité vont
se produire
l'accord de paris sur le climat de la
coop 21 prévoyait d'unir les efforts de
tous pour éviter une hausse de plus de 2
degrés au mieux 25 degrés mais un
nouveau rapport de l'onu s'avère brûlant
il faudrait être cette fois plus
drastiques pour espérer limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degré les nouveaux
engagements pris pour 2030 permettra de
réduire les émissions projeté en 2030 de
7 5% seulement alors que des réductions
de 30% et de 55% sont nécessaires pour
limiter le réchauffement à 2 degrés et
un bien moins cinq degrés respectivement
chaque année les cops et sommet dit de
la dernière chance sont des échecs et
fixe des objectifs très en deçà des
préconisations des scientifiques
d'ores et déjà les leaders craignent que
comme la coop 25 le nouveau sommet soit
un nouveau naufrage patzebike brioches
des soyons clairs il existe un risque
sérieux que glasgow ne réussissent pas
plusieurs annonces récentes sur le
climat pourrait donner la pression d'un
tableau plus rose et malheureusement il
s'agit d'une illusion dix années l'eau
je suis très inquiet parce que sa part
est telle dans le mauvais sens et nous
pourrions ne pas obtenir les accords
dont nous avons besoin c'est quitte ou
double schengen comment en est on arrivé
là alors que les catastrophes sont déjà
en train de se produire l'accord de
paris est faible non contraignant
certains états affiche de grandes
ambitions mais aucune feuille de route
pour expliquer comment il compte
procéder et quelques pays font bloc pour
ne pas avancer le brésil la chine l'inde
l'australie
habib saoudite ou encore la pologne qui
mise sur son charbon veulent en faire le
moins possible à la dernière comme par
exemple la chine l'inde et le brésil ont
réussi à gagner du temps et entériner
leur inertie ils ont exigé des pays
développés qu'ils honorent leurs
engagements en matière de climat avant
de s'engager eux mêmes une pression
irresponsables qui aboutit à une
nouvelle échéance 2023 alors que le
temps presse de plus les textes sont
vagues appelle à revoir les objectifs et
ne s'engage que sur le long terme autre
problème il convient d'aider les pays du
sud à se développer de manière vertueuse
un fonds vert de l'onu a été créé en ce
sens mais les états riches ne respectent
pas leurs promesses il devait donner 100
milliards de 2009 à 2021 chaque année
mais cette année la cagnotte n'a atteint
que 79 milliards côté français et nos
émissions sont en baisse mais pas
suffisamment la loi climat n'est pas
assez ambitieuse pour que l'hexagone
atteigne ses objectifs
la france a d'ailleurs été condamné pour
une action climatique dans le cadre de
la poursuite de la sphère du siècle un
exemple cuisant reste-t-il de l'espoir
oui par exemple entre 2017 et 2018 les
émissions de co2 ont diminué de 2,5 pour
cent dans l'ensemble de l'union
européenne certains pays comme les etats
unis la russie le japon montre une
tendance à la baisse des émissions et
peuvent montrer la voie à la chine ou à
l'inde par exemple mais les intérêts
court termiste de certains pays du sud
et le manque de détermination des pays
du nord risquent bien de reléguer les
ambitions de la coop 26 à 20 milieu sous
la montée des eaux